okay so there's a hypothesis or to use
the term colloquially and not
scientifically don't yell at me there's
a theory that Joe Biden has been pulled
in to run in the 2020 Democratic primary
specifically to enable super-delegates
to decide who the nominee is in a way
that will prevent Bernie Sanders from
being the nominee now I want to be
really clear it seems every time I talk
about Joe Biden people react as if I'm
either praising him or criticizing him
we'll all I'm doing is telling you what
is being said and analyzing it so let's
discuss it to understand this theory you
need to understand how the DNC changed
its super delegate rules since the 2016
primary more and more people are
emailing me emailing me about this and
some people say David you've got to
debunk this and others say David you've
got to expose that this is what's going
on so let's see what's actually going on
and it gets a little wonky but you you
need to understand how it works in
democratic primaries you have to get 15%
of the vote to get any delegates so
imagine that there's a state with ten
delegates up for grabs and they a lot
those delegates proportionally meaning
it's not winner-take-all
you might think if I get 10% of the vote
I get 10% of the delegates meaning one
out of the ten delegates but you would
be wrong and the reason you're wrong is
that many states have a 15% minimum
required so everyone who gets under 15%
of the vote in some states gets 0
delegates whatsoever so when there's a
really crowded field you can't end up
with two candidates getting over 15% and
everybody else could conceivably split
everything that's left with no one
getting more than 15% of the vote and
what you end up with is a primary where
you might have 10 different or 12
different or 14 different candidates but
only two of the candidates actually pick
up any delegates from those states that
gets us to the discussion about
super-delegates the DNC after the 2016
Fiasco changes the rules to prevent
super-delegates from getting to decide
who is the nominee at the convention on
what's called the first ballot at the
convention there can be multiple ballots
multiple rounds of voting and the rule
was changed so that if super-delegates
would
side the outcome on the first ballot
their votes effectively aren't counted
but in the same set of rules if no
candidate gets a majority of the votes
on the first ballot
there is a second ballot and in that
second ballot the super-delegates are
allowed to vote and ultimately are
allowed to decide the outcome so what
happens when you have more and more
candidates running in 2020 is that it
becomes more and more likely that on the
first ballot nobody is going to get a
majority nobody's going to get 50% plus
one of the boat so the theory is by
adding Joe Biden an establishment
Democrat who is polling very well is
that if Biden keeps polling at 25% or if
Biden even drops the twenty percent or
two fifteen percent or even twelve
percent frankly that Biden can take
enough delegates in primaries throughout
the primary process to ensure that on
the first ballot at the Democratic
convention nobody gets that 50% plus one
that they need this leads to a second
ballot at which point all of the
super-delegates can come in and pick
somebody other than Bernie Sanders could
be Kamala Harris could be Pete Budaj
edge if he ends up being the DNC choice
it could be Biden if the ideas that
Biden will actually be the nominee so
first question is this idea
conspiratorial well conspiratorial
conspiratorial means it's suggestive of
a secret plan made by a group of people
the Democratic establishment we know has
been meeting to figure out what to do
about what they call the Bernie Sanders
problem so in that sense it's not
conspirator a rational ikan spirit
oriole but here's where I think it
doesn't make total sense which is that
you don't really need to run Biden
specifically for this reason what I mean
is running Biden so that he wins more is
kind of obvious right you you wit you
you run Biden because he has support and
he'll get more support than Bernie and
maybe he'll actually be the nominee
that's simpler and to me it's more
likely because if the plan is you run
Biden to take enough support from Bernie
so that then some other person is chosen
on the second ballot at the DNC it's
just more complicated than it needs to
be Biden is going to take some votes
from Bernie he's gonna take some votes
from Warren he's gonna take some votes
for mayor Pete and there's gonna be a
sort of thinning of the field over the
next six months before any of the
primaries actually take place that's
going to do a lot more to determine who
is ultimately the nominee then Biden's
presence would do in the second round of
voting by the time we get to the DNC so
is the DNC working towards their goal
which may be it may be to stop Bernie
Sanders of course is the idea that Biden
is a plant to give the nomination to
Kamala or Buddha judge reasonable I
don't see evidence of that right now I
think the simplest explanation if we
apply Occam's razor right Occam's razor
is normally applied to science but it
works here we shouldn't make more
assumptions than the minimum needed
should we assume Biden has been drafted
by establishment Democrats to get just
enough support that he prevents a first
ballot win by Bernie
so that then on the second ballot
super-delegates vote for Kamala Harris
well there's a much simpler explanation
which is Biden was encouraged to run by
the establishment because they liked him
more than Bernie and they want him to be
the nominee and until we have evidence
that it's much more complicated than
that
I think we shouldn't go to the more
complicated explanations if you disagree
with my analysis then please let me know